[Musique]
depuis les 30 dernières secondes
vous avez tous pensé à au moins un
vêtement qui traînait inutilement dans
votre garde-robe
cette petite baisse par exemple
normalement sur devenu trop courte mais
qui va tellement bien que ce pantalon
que finalement vous la gardez ou bien ce
pull dans lequel il ya un trou que du
coup vous avez mis de côté en vous
promettant qu'un jour vous allez le
réparer mais ça fait deux ans qu'il
attend vous vous reconnaissez moi aussi
et c'est normal des histoires comme ça
on a tous avoir une penderie avec une ou
deux pièces qui traîne c'est bien sûr
pas un crime
cela dit de nombreuses études avancent
des chiffres beaucoup plus interpellant
comme par exemple 70% dans notre
garde-robe ne seraient pas portées selon
différentes sources
il y a aussi une dizaine voire 50 pardon
20 kg
le vêtement qui seraient jetés chaque
année par personne et on en arrache et
très une trentaine ça ressemble un peu à
du gaspillage alimentaire nous mais
avoir une garde-robe bien remplie rempli
à craquer c'est surtout un indicateurs
alarmants de notre consommation
excessive de vêtements qui engendre une
production excessive est gagnant mais
cette production est surtout un problème
au regard de la l'énergie utilisée et
pollution qu'elle engendre et des droits
de l'homme de la femme et de l'enfant
constamment bafoués savez vous que pour
produire un jean
il faut environ un million e par an 1 kg
des guides et de coton et pour avoir ce
kilogramme de coton il vous faut 5000 à
25 mille litres d'eau 2 kg d'engrais
chimiques et 75 g de pesticides et si on
parle uniquement du coton donc pas de
transport ni de lavage anoblissement en
peinture extérieure donc s'efface un
petit peu à tous ces chiffres que moi
j'ai décidé de faire quelque chose à mon
échelle et j'ai ouvert une boutique de
seconde main ici à namur car j'estime
que la seconde main est un moyen de
réduire un petit peu son empreinte
écologique et très peu de temps après
l'ouverture du magasin
j'avais comme projet de m'associer avec
une styliste pour montrer qu'il est
possible de s'habiller de manière très
joli avec de vieux vêtements et ce à
partir de ce moment là que l'uci est
rentré en scène tout à fait en fait
l'idée de retravailler des vêtements de
seconde main me trottait déjà en tête
depuis un petit moment
en ayant fait des études en
anthropologie avant ma formation de
stylisme les questions d'éthique et de
durabilité dans le secteur de la mode se
sont rapidement imposés à moi quand on
sait que l'on produit 57 millions de
tonnes de déchets textiles
chaque année il ya de quoi se poser des
questions alors du coup quand j'ai vu
que tu cherches une styliste pour un
projet autour de la seconde main moi
j'ai foncé directement sans trop savoir
de quoi je me lançais en fait et
heureusement parce que si on m'avait dit
que j'allais devoir parler devant 600
personnes
le crunch aurait directement fait une
vidéo mais du coup à ce moment là tu
savais déjà qu'on allait participer au
thé leaks non non non pas du tout
rassuré mais c'était c'était vraiment un
projet que j'avais moi à la boutique dès
le départ est en fait un ou deux mois
après l'ouverture j'ai quelques
personnes mutées dit qu'ils sont venus
me rendre visite et m'ont demandé de
faire une collaboration que j'ai tout de
suite accepté
un peu comme toi je n'ai pas du tout
vers quoi j'allais et peu de temps donc
après que tu es pris part au projet je
leur ai présenté le projet
et elles m'ont dit que c'est super et
hyper ravi en tout cas pour nous ce soir
c'est vraiment une super opportunité de
pouvoir vous présenter notre projet mais
on tenait à préciser qu on est vraiment
loin d'être les seuls à croire ans
d'alternative des projets dans le
domaine de la slow fashion
il en existe plein que ce soit à
l'international en belgique et même à
namur il en existe plusieurs
et toi avec tes études de stylisme à
tubes peut-être des conseils ou quoi
vous rachetez de manière durable
tout à fait pour le consommateur on peut
facilement privilégier la qualité à la
quantité
regardez où ont été fabriqués nos
vêtements se renseigner sur les marques
que l'on aimerait racheter ce sont
quelques exemples de choses que l'on
peut faire du côté des créateurs c'est
un peu plus complexe mais c'est selon
moi là qu'est le véritable enjeu pour le
futur on peut par exemple design et des
vêtements qui produisent directement
beaucoup moins de déchets textiles
on peut aussi privilégier l'utilisation
de ce qu'on appelle les indésirables
donc ce sont toutes ces choses qui
aujourd'hui termine généralement à la
poubelle le défi c'est de montrer qu'en
fait ils ont énormément de potentiel
donc ce sont par exemple les déchets
issus de la production également les
fins de stocks de tissus industriels ou
même des vêtements qui sont habiles et
ce qu'on veut vraiment montrer c'est que
grâce à ces indésirables
on peut en fait faire des créations qui
sont uniques et un coût réduit
c'est exactement ce qu'on a fait pour
notre collection récup qu'on vous
présente aujourd'hui cette collection
attentes de revaloriser des vêtements
qui autrefois étaient abîmées ou un peu
trop difficile à porter et est donc on a
repris des pièces de la boutique qui
était donc invendables et illzach
travaillait à 100% donc sa collection
harbour quand même
des coupes simples mais moderne il y à
du streetwear comme des pièces un peu
plus chic et masculin féminin et nous
espérons que via cette collection vous
serez aussi convaincu comme nous que la
seconde main a beaucoup d'avenir
beaucoup de potentiel beaucoup de
possibilités alors on vous laisse en
compagnie de nour cannelle laurent
xavier gilly et amandine qui vont vous
montrer que l'on peut s'habiller avec
des vêtements qui était décédée à la
poubelle sans pour autant avoir un sac
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au
m
maintenant
la fin
mettez la main
b
oui
[Musique]
depuis
hu
[Musique]
m
les mots
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chemin faisant
c
[Musique]
été fait
m
moi si
[Musique]
g
m
[Musique]
gagné
il
[Musique]